contrairement au canada l'état américain
de la pennsylvanie a choisi de taxer
l'utilisation de services numériques
payants comme netflix depuis un peu plus
d'un an la taxe de vente de 6 %
s'applique pour la consommation en ligne
que ce soit pour regarder des vidéos
écouter de la musique ou encore
télécharger des applications
quand une entreprise un client dont
l'adresse de facturation est en
pennsylvanie elle doit percevoir cette
taxe pour le consommateur ici sur un
forfait de base de netflix arsène
dollars 99 par mois ça représente une
augmentation de 40 mm sur la facture
mensuelle pour l'état cette taxe a
rapporté 63 millions de dollars
américains en un peu plus d'un an
la pratique n'a pas chassé netflix c'est
ici dans la grande région de pittsburgh
qui a été tourné mind hunter l'une des
plus récentes séries du géant américain
aux etats unis la pennsylvanie n'est pas
le seul endroit où on doit payer une
taxe pour consommer du contenu vidéo
la ville de chicago et l'état de
washington notamment ont des systèmes
semblables